um i
i i've had guys uh ask me like uh rolo
hey i want to uh
i want to have my own kid but i don't
want to have a wife i want to be like
dave's like
they it's almost like you know how like
women can become single parents if they
want to they can just freeze their eggs
or they can just get a sperm donor or
whatever they have like a right to have
children right
yeah for a guy to do that it's like next
to impossible you have to be like
very very rich to do something like that
and you got to find an egg donor and
you've got a really
especially if you want to be your
biological progeny right
um but i tell those guys like even if
that was
if even if it was easier for you to do
that like an artificial womb or whatever
these guys are talking about i'm like
even if you could do that easily i know
that easily you're not going to be
you're not it's i don't think it's going
to work out the way that you think it's
going to work out no
no i don't think it's a good idea single
fathers raise better children than
single mothers
sorry not sorry that's a statistic and i
found that out you know
going back to my divorce right and check
your phone by the way because i sent you
that picture i just want you to
get like a recent image but don't show
it up on the screen
[Music]
how old is she now like eleven twelve
twelve yeah well i'm gonna i'll send you
a
little bit after the show i'll send you
something yeah um but um what you're
going through
yeah like the the the um whole like
frying pan of the forehead moment going
through the divorce was when i started
reading like these um forums with
um men and women going through the
divorce machine and the experience was
very very different and there was a lot
of like
um moments where like these
these divorce people were talking about
how their children would behave
how they were a product of a certain you
know
like household whatever the dynamic
looked like especially if it was
divorced and they didn't have access to
the father and i started to realize that
men are really important and there's and
there's been
no conversations about this so that was
the first thing the second thing was
after i got divorced and i started
dating right away obviously because i
was like i'm done i'm out
and there was a lot of women that i that
i came across
um who were either divorced or you know
i was older at the time
i was around 39 so i was at that time
because i wasn't red pill i was
i was dating around same age right um
and it came across a lot of women that
had like severe daddy issues it's one of
the reasons why in my book i have that
that red flag chapters and and why you
want to avoid
women with daddy issues and it seemed
like a lot of the times
they didn't really know why they had
daddy issues but they had them
and when you start to probe and ask
questions like what happened to your dad
you know did your mom push him out of
the house you know do you
run off and they didn't really have an
explanation they didn't have an
understanding why
but the thing that that really put it
all together
there's this um doctor's name's dr
leonard sachs it's
s-a-x and if you look at the um uh
top comment pinned in all my videos i've
got somewhere in there
um an amazon link to my bookstore where
i recommend read so i've got all of
rolos books my stuff in there and a
bunch of evil psych
and one of the books i have in there um
is from
leonard sacks and he came to toronto as
a speaker for an eo event to talk to
entrepreneurs about raising kids
and there's a huge difference between um
what he came across
with raising daughters and boys like
boys have a different relationship with
screens than girls do
right um there's a meme somewhere out
there that somebody's pointed out but
girls generally have cameras pointed at
them
boys usually have cameras pointed
outwards
and they stare at screens because
they're playing games you know
competitively
girls on the other hand are comparing
themselves to other girls so
if they can get a picture that's more
provocative i'm going to try to put this
up this way you know kind of slide it up
with the
downhill shot to get down the top rather
than over here and that gets some more
likes than doing that they're going to
be doing this
right so one of the questions that
somebody asked which i want to get to
about you know when you think it's
appropriate to give a daughter a cell
phone and we'll talk to
talk about that in a little bit but
really really important information to
get your head around it
if you want to have productive kids even
if you have a son and a daughter or if
you just have one daughter and a bunch
of sons i think it's important that you
have
healthy balanced children in that
household to begin with because if you
have a messed up girl in your household
that's really going to throw everything
for for a loop it's like you know you
you know you said it earlier with that
whole chris rock thing like you know
the clear heel from the pole right like
you want to
keep well away from that but yeah girls
girls are
like i'm thankful in one regard because
i see how bad boys have it
like i don't know how guys today
are raising boys to be men in the
environment they live in like
a conversation like would you tell your
daughter to get married
obviously right i want i would like her
to get married but i want her to marry
the guy i want her to marry a guy
who is who's got his [ __ ] together right
i want him to get a son would you tell
your son to get married
not right now not certainly not not at
his age i would say you know don't even
i would tell him
tell us people ask me i would tell my
son exactly what i tell everybody else
is stay you know single stay you know
spin plates until you get to be about 30
years old
understand like i tell i everybody
thinks that i gotta keep this secret
from my family or something i was like i
know i don't
it's like i would tell i told my nephew
the same thing right i would tell my
my my daughter look you're and i have i
said look you're 23 right now you are at
the peak of your game right now
you will always look on these years as
having the most potential
make the most of it i'm not going to
tell her anything less because she needs
you know if you you want her to be
competitive that's how you tell that you
tell them the truth
like i've told you before he's like like
what what uh when i was talking about
like uh
what was it uh homeschooling right when
i was talking about that i was kind of
against that the reason i was against
homeschooling is because
i think that it in some way insulates
kids not something like well they're
going to be like social
you know morons or something like that
it's related today it's it's incident
years of essentially homeschooling with
this pandemic lockdown because they're
sitting around doing all their school
from their bedroom on an ipad
but i would rather prepare my child to
prepare my daughter
to be resilient and teflon and to like
to critically think so when people try
to throw [ __ ] at her or they try to
throw all the stuff that we
like you can go and look at any any
podcast today where they've got lots of
women on and everybody's holding them
accountable i don't care which one
they all repeat the same thing over and
over again i don't care if they came
from a big family that's still together
or if they had like a single mom or
whatever
they're all repeating the same thing so
the best way you can keep
your baby off the pole or keep your your
baby uh you know
sane and uh have a different opinion of
things
is you first of all you got to be
involved we know that i mean
children watch what you do they don't
listen to what you say and even to this
day
i mean as you know i can get long-winded
so if i'm trying to like impart some
like
fatherly wisdom if 10 of that sinks in
i'm happy and and that's a kid thing but
it's also
like people will ask me all the time
like what would you tell your 18 year
old self rollo i said i wouldn't even
bother
my 18 year old self wouldn't listen to
jack [ __ ] yeah
what they're really asking me is what is
your advice for
uh the kids today which in that case is
like okay well then i can give you some
then i can give you some real actionable
advice
but we ha i think if you want to keep
your baby off the pole and by i mean
that metaphorically if you want to
like hav if you want to build strong
daughters who are who are
on top of their game they're not going
to be you know only fans girls are going
to
whatever the poll is per that particular
era
you need to uh i think it begins in
childhood it begins as far back as like
five years old when kids when you know
kids are sponges
but it also it requires you to set a
masculine ideal and it requires your
wife to set
the female uh feminine ideal so
the model for and that's why they call
them role models right the model for
masculinity that most women have is an
absent father
or uh or he's been kicked out of the
house for whatever reason maybe his
fault or or
or basically a gynocentric social order
has removed him
from that house and he is not as
influential and he is not as important
as he could be if he were to stay
in there and to like sort of assert
himself as a positively masculine
uh role in there and to be unapologetic
about it
and just and to be uh that's why i said
the basis of it all of this of course is
to internalize
red pill awareness and live it out and
let your
son or daughter for that matter uh see
that this is how my dad is
and this is how it works for him and
this is why and this is why rolo and his
wife are still together
and this is why they have a you know
coming up on 25 years of marriage and
this is why i'm a good kid and
it's you at some point along the way if
that's the case for you and i know it's
been the case for me
is that eventually when that girl when
that boy gets to be
into their 20s they'll say my my parents
are different
my my daughter has lots and lots of
friends to this day but certainly when
she was in high school
and i would say about 80 to 90 percent
of them
came from single mother homes or they
had came from a broken home
i did too i didn't have my parents i was
pete
so that's a rarity and she realizes that
she appreciates the fact that she still
has two
functional parents that are in love with
each other and really are
good for each other and a positive
influence on her life
you